anyway amazon says it's going to stop
accepting payments made using uk issued
visa credit cards from january the
online retailer said it was because of
what it called the high fees that visa
charges for processing credit card
transactions well helen and smith our
business correspondent is here helen and
this is basically one big company
bullying another big company isn't it
yeah that's absolutely right ian and the
consumer left with a bit of an
inconvenience if you're a consumer that
uses a visa credit card with a company
like amazon
but i think as you say it is something
of a power play it broke this morning
when amazon emailed out its uk-based
customers saying that from january the
19th uh it will no longer accept visa
credit cards registered in the uk as
part of the process and said
specifically that it was because of the
high prices
that visa charged for those payments and
it followed up with a statement
essentially saying that uh with time the
technical advances means that these
costs should be going down and in fact
uh they haven't been so really making a
very a sort of powerful statement there
visa responded in term with a quite a
punchy statement they reassured
customers that they would be able to use
those credit cards over the christmas
period but then went on to say we're
incredibly disappointed uh and that when
consumer choice is limited nobody wins
visa said there so clearly uh very very
unhappy about this uh merchant service
charges on credit cards are no new thing
they vary depending on what type of
credit card you're using they're higher
for the merchants if you're using a
commercial card and while there's been
debate before about whether those
charges are right and whether the
consumer should be paying for it using a
certain surcharge
it's very rare that there's a company
that has the power that amazon have to
put their foot down and make a statement
that they're simply not going to accept
it anymore it'll be a huge loss of a
chunk of business for visa so
it'll be very interesting to see how
visa go on to respond after this